-Our first guest tonight is
an Academy Award-winning actor.
He narrates
"Life on Our Planet,"
which is streaming
now on Netflix.
Please welcome back to the show
Morgan Freeman, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back!
-Thank you.
Nice to be back.
-It's nice to have you --
It's nice to have you here,
back in New York City.
-Thank you.
-When did you first
come to the city?
-I first came in
nineteen sixty...one, I think.
-All right.
-'60, '60.
1959 -- 1960.
-1960.
-But I only stayed five months.
-Okay.
-And then I fled.
[ Laughter ]
And I went to San Francisco.
-Okay.
-Stayed in San Francisco
for about three years
and then came back more ready.
-Oh, okay.
So did you -- as an actor
more ready or --
-Yep. As a performer.
-Okay. Gotcha.
-'Cause I had taken dance.
-Oh, that's right.
You did it all.
Yeah, you did it all.
I remember we talked --
You danced at the World's Fair
here in New York City.
-Yeah, I --
[ Chuckles ]
[ Laughter ]
You know that?
-I mean, you're the only person
I've ever met who's danced
at a World's Fair.
-Right. 1984 World's Fair,
New York world's fair.
-That's amazing.
So, you come back in 1963,
you're a performer.
-Yeah.
-And how did you --
how did you find New York City?
-In 1963?
-Yeah.
-Well, it's probably the most
exciting place, you know,
particularly that I was ready to
make the move into the big-time.
By that, I mean get a job.
[ Laughter ]
-Just a paying job?
-Right.
-And now do you was -- your
first New York City apartment --
Probably not a penthouse
with a beautiful view
of the park or anything.
-No, no, no.
I had one-room
in a place on 12th Street
and Avenue A,
called Paradise Alley.
-All right. And was it -- was it
more Paradise or more Alley?
[ Laughter ]
-It was enough of both
to get the name.
-There you go.
-A lot of young dancers,
singers, musicians,
actors lived there.
And it wasn't --
It wasn't subsidized.
It was just affordable.
-You were doing --
How long in New York
before you did "Hello, Dolly!"
on Broadway?
-I did "Hello, Dolly!"
on Broadway.
I got the job in November '67.
-Mm-hmm.
-And I worked there
for 11 months.
-And was that
one of the first,
"I think I've made it"
moments for you?
-Yeah, absolutely.
-And was doing a show
for 11 months,
was it exciting the whole time?
-I was working
with Pearl Bailey.
-There you go.
-Every night was a joy.
-That's pretty exciting.
-Yeah.
-You've also -- you also
had shows that had
shorter runs on Broadway.
-[ Chuckles ]
-What was your show
that only had nine performances?
-"The Mighty Jets."
-Yeah.
-Did you have any sense
on the first night that it would
only be there for nine nights?
-I had that sense
while we were rehearsing.
[ Laughter ]
That's the truth.
-Yeah.
So kind of sometimes you know?
-Yeah, sometimes, you know,
"This is not going to work."
-Yeah. Now, an interesting
thing happened, though,
because the show
only had nine performances,
but you received
a Tony nomination.
-Yes.
-Is that sort of cold comfort
when you receive praise
for a show
that had such a short run?
-It is. Yeah.
-Yeah.
-Operative word,
however, is comfort.
-Uh-huh.
-Yeah. I mean, it's like,
"Okay."
[ Laughter ]
-Who decided --
Was it something you decided,
"I'm going to be a performer,"
or was it decided for you?
-It was decided for me.
-Yeah? How about?
-I was born.
-How long? How old were you?
-You were born, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-That's a fact.
-Sorry.
-Did you know -- at what age
did you think,
"Oh, I'm gonna be better
at this than other things"?
-I don't know.
-Yeah.
-I just was always able.
I always went whole hog.
-Mm-hmm.
-When we played --
Like, I had a friend
when I was like 5, 6.
And we played, like,
horse and buggy.
You just put a clothesline,
a rope, around your waist,
and he holds on to it
and goes -- [ Clicks tongue ]
[ Laughter ]
-It's still -- sometimes kids
who have the talent
don't have the confidence
to then go do a school play
or join the theater club.
Was that something --
As soon as you got to school --
-I had a mother
who was very into --
-Oh, that helps.
-Yeah.
And I had three brothers
who -- and we were all,
on some level,
artistic, you know?
-We're gonna take
a quick break
and then talk about this Netflix
documentary you're narrating.
But I wonder,
you get asked so often,
what's the worst thing
you've been asked to narrate?
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, you know,
somebody's telephone number.
-Oh, people ask you
to leave messages and stuff?
-Yeah.
I don't --
You don't seem to me
like the kind of guy
who would like doing that.
[ Laughter ]
-Don't -- Don't -- Don't --
Don't get me into trouble.
[ Laughter ]
-We'll be right back with more
from Morgan Freeman.